>>> SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY IS
DEFENDING HIS ACTIONS FROM THE
DAY OF THE INSURRECTION.
HAWLEY SPEAKING TO CNN MOMENTS
AGO.
LET'S GET TO MANU RANDJU, WHAT D
HE TELL YOU?
>> Reporter: HE WAS DEFIANT.
HE RECALLED WHAT HAPPENED ON THE
DAY.
HE WAS THE FIRST SENATOR TO SAY
THAT HE WOULD OBJECT TO THE
ELECTORAL RESULTS OF
PENNSYLVANIA AND THEN ULTIMATELY
TED CRUZ OBJECTED TO ARIZONA.
THAT LED TO A DEBATE THAT
HAPPENED ON THE SENATE FLOOR AND
ON THE HOUSE FLOOR.
PEOPLE CRITICIZED HIM FOR GIVING
FALSE HOPE TO THE PEOPLE WHO
CAME HERE ON JANUARY 6th, THAT
SOMEHOW THE ELECTION COULD BE
OVERTURNED.
AND THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
REVEALED IN THEIR HEARING THAT A
CAPITOL HILL POLICE OFFICER HAD
TESTIFIED THAT HE -- WHEN HE
GAVE A FIST PUMP TO THE CROWD
BEFORE THE VIOLENCE BEGAN THAT
THAT RILED UP THE CROWD.
THAT WAS FROM THE WORDS FROM A
POLICE OFFICER TO THE COMMITTEE.
ALSO THEY SHOWED HIM RUNNING, A
VIDEO OF HIM RUNNING FROM THE
RIOTERS WHEN THEY BREACHED THE
CAPITOL AS THE SENATORS WERE
GETTING INTO A SECURE LOCATION.
SO WE CAUGHT UP WITH HIM TODAY
ABOUT ALL OF THAT, AND HE MADE
CLEAR THAT HE WAS NOT -- HE
CONTENDED THAT THIS WAS TROLLING
AND WAS DEFIANT IN HIS RESPONSE.
>> THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
SAID THAT THEY TALKED TO A
CAPITOL HILL POLICE OFFICER WHO
SAID WHEN YOU MADE THE FIST PUMP
YOU RILED UP THE CROWD.
DO YOU REGRET THAT FIST PUMP?
>> I DON'T REGRET ANYTHING I DID
ON THAT DAY.
AND YOU KNOW, IT'S A PRIVILEGE
TO BE ATTACKED BY THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE HELP WITH MY FUNDRAISING.
IT'S BEEN TREMENDOUS.
>> Reporter: WHAT ABOUT THE
VIDEO?
THE FACT THAT THEY RELEASED THE
VIDEO OF YOU RUNNING?
>> THIS IS JUST AN ATTEMPT TO
TROLL.
AND LISTEN, I DON'T REGRET
ANYTHING I DID ON THAT DAY.
AND THE REASON I'M BEING
ATTACKED BY THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE IS BECAUSE I'M IN
THEIR WAY.
THE STAND THAT I TOOK IS ONE
THAT I DON'T REGRET AND ONE I
WON'T BACK DOWN FROM.
>> Reporter: SO WHEN HE'S
TALKING ABOUT THE STAND -- THE
FUNDRAISING, RECALL WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE IMMEDIATE
AFTERMATH OF THE PICTURE THAT
SHOWED HIM WITH THAT FIST PUMP,
THEY PUT THAT ON A -- ON A
COFFEE MUG.
HE LATER FUND-RAISED OFF OF
THIS.
AND THIS IS WHAT HE'S TALKING
ABOUT.
APPARENTLY IT HELPED HIS
FUND-RAISING.
YOU'RE SEEING ONE SENATOR WHO
OBJECTED.
ONE OF THE FEW WHO DID TRY TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTORAL RESULTS
ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE MAKING
CLEAR HE HAS NO REGRETS FOR HIS
STAND.
GUYS?
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THAT TO US.
>>> SO ALSO THIS, THE JUST'S
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION INTO THE
JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION IS
MOVING CLOSER TO FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THERE'S THIS -- "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" HAS FRESH REPORTING ON
PREVIOUSLY UNKNOWN EMAILS AMONG
TRUMP ADVISERS ADMITTING THAT
THEIR FAKE ELECTOR SCHEME WAS
DUBIOUS AT BEST.
THE REPORT INCLUDES AN EMAIL
FROM A PHOENIX-BASED LAWYER WHO
HELPED ORGANIZE THE PRO-TRUMP
ELECTORS IN ARIZONA, WRITING TO
AN ADVISER WITH THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
IT READS THIS, IN PART IN THE
EMAIL, "WE WOULD JUST BE SENDING
IN FAKE ELECTORAL VOTES TO PENCE
SO THAT SOMEONE IN CONGRESS CAN
MAKE AN OBJECTION WHEN THEY
START COUNTING VOTES AND START
ARGUING THAT THE FAKE VOTES
SHOULD BE COUNTED."
THAT ATTORNEY LATER ALSO
WRITING, QUOTE, ALTERNATIVE
VOTES IS PROBABLY A BETTER TERM
THAN FAKE VOTES.
JOINING ME CNN POLITICAL ANALYST
DAVID GREGORY.
AND BACK WITH US, SENIOR JUSTICE
CORRESPONDENT EVAN PEREZ.
LET'S GET TO THIS, BUT DAVID, I
WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION TO
JOSH HAWLEY AND HIS BRIEF
CONVERSATION THAT HE HAD WITH --
WITH MANU ON THE HILL SAYING --
I THINK NO SURPRISE THAT HE SAYS
HE DOESN'T REGRET ANY OF HIS
ACTIONS, BUT JUST HIS TONE, HIS
APPROACH, AND HIS ADMITTING THAT
IT'S ALL HELPING HIS
FUND-RAISING NOW.
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S
EMBARRASSING, FRANKLY, THAT WE
HAVE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE LIKE
JOSH HAWLEY WHO, BY THE WAY, IS
A HIGHLY INTELLIGENT, HIGHLY
EDUCATED PERSON.
AND WHO HAS WEAPONIZED HIS
EDUCATION AND INTELLIGENCE IN
FURTHERING DEMONSTRABLY FALSE
CLAIMS ABOUT A FAKE ELECTION,
MAKING HIMSELF AN ALLY OF A
SCHEME TO PERPETUATE A PLAN TO
STEAL AN ELECTION.
AND IS SO IMPRESSED WITH HIMSELF
THAT THAT'S THE PATH HE'S
FOLLOWING POLITICALLY IN
MISSOURI AND IS RAISING MONEY
OFF OF IT.
YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST THE STATE OF
REPUBLICAN POLITICS AT LEAST IN
MISSOURI THAT GIVES HIM THE
BACKING FROM AT LEAST SOME
QUARTER OF THE ELECTORATE FOR
THAT.
THERE'S NO FACTUAL BASIS FOR IT.
THERE'S FNO DEFENSE OF IT.
IF PEOPLE LIKE IT DESPITE HIS
WILLFUL IGNORANCE OF WHAT THE
FACTS ARE.
>> YEAH.
AND EVAN, TO THIS NEW REPORTING
THAT ADDS MORE TO ALL OF THIS,
THESE ADVISERS, THESE ATTORNEYS
AROUND THE PRESIDENT AND THE
CAMPAIGN ADMITTING THAT THEY
KNEW THE ELECTORS WERE FAKE,
DIDN'T HAVE LEGAL STANDING.
NOW THAT THIS IS OUT THERE, WHAT
DO YOU THINK IT DOES?
>> WELL, ONE OF THE THINGS IT
DOES -- AND GUARANTEED THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ALREADY HAS
ALL OF THESE CONVERSATIONS, WE
KNOW THEY SUBPOENAED EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THESE DOZENS OF
ELECTORS IN THE SEVEN
BATTLEGROUND STATES, KATE.
WE KNOW THAT THEY HAVE ALL OF
THIS.
AND WHAT IT GETS TO IS THEIR
STATE OF MIND, RIGHT, THAT THEIR
INTENT.
IF YOU ARE DOING THIS WHEN YOU
KNOW THAT IT IS LEGALLY
QUESTIONABLE, THAT REALLY DOES
RAISE YOUR LEGAL EXPOSURE.
AND SO FOR ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
-- AND I THINK THIS IS WHAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS SPEAKING TO
YESTERDAY WHEN HE MADE SURE THAT
THE LENS IS AS WIDE AS POSSIBLE
IN THIS INVESTIGATION.
WHAT HE'S TELLING THEM IS, HEY,
IF YOU GUYS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
YOUR LEGAL EXPOSURE, PERHAPS YOU
WANT TO COME IN AND, YOU KNOW,
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE WILL END UP
COOPERATING AND FIGURE OUT HOW
TO HELP THIS JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATION TO GO HIGHER.
IN THE END, THAT IS THE GOAL.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE BEHIND ALL OF
THIS, NOT ONLY JOHN EASTMAN AND
RUDY GIULIANI WHO ARE THE ONES
DIRECTLY IN TOUCH WITH THESE
FACELF
FAKE ELECTORS, BUT THE MAN
BEHIND IT ALL, WHICH IS DONALD
TRUMP.
SO THAT'S -- YOU CAN SEE WHAT
THE GOAL OF THE INVESTIGATION
IS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER THEY'LL
GET THERE.
CERTAINLY I THINK WHAT IT TELLS
YOU IS THERE'S A BODY OF PEOPLE,
A LARGE NUMBER, WHO ARE POSSIBLE
TARGETS OF THIS INVESTIGATION
THAT NEED TO START COOPERATING.
>> DAVID, THERE'S ANOTHER PIECE
OF TROUBLING EVIDENCE THAT
ACTUALLY CAME OUT FROM THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
IT'S FORMER ACTING DEFENSE
SECRETARY CHRIS MILLER.
AND HE IS TELLING THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE THAT TRUMP NEVER GAVE
HIM AN ORDER TO HAVE 10,000
TROOPS AT THE READY TO DEPLOY.
LET ME PLAY A LITTLE BIT OF WHAT
THE COMMITTEE RELEASED.
>> THERE WAS NO DIRECT ORDER
FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP TO PUT
10,000 TROOPS TO BE ON THE READY
FOR JANUARY 6th?
CORRECT?
>> NO.
YEAH, THAT'S CORRECT.
THERE WAS NO DIRECT -- THERE WAS
NO ORDER FROM THE PRESIDENT.
>> TRUMP PUT OUT A STATEMENT, OF
COURSE, SAYING THAT HE
ESSENTIALLY HAD DONE THAT,
SUGGESTED THAT.
THIS GETS TO SOMETHING THAT I
THINK THE COMMITTEE HAS SO FAR
LEFT UNANSWERED SOMEWHAT, AND I
THINK IS A BIG PROBLEM WHICH IS
WHY THE POLICE WERE LEFT LIKE
SITTING DUCKS IS ESSENTIALLY HOW
SOME HAVE DESCRIBED IT, WHEN SO
MANY PEOPLE KNEW HOW REAL THE
THREAT WAS AHEAD OF TIME.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, I THINK THERE'S JUST A
-- A GROSS DERELICTION OF DUTY
ON THE PART OF THE PRESIDENT WHO
WAS BEING TOLD FROM MULTIPLE
PEOPLE HOW THIS WAS SHAPING UP
AND HOW DANGEROUS IT COULD BE,
WOULD BE, AND BECAME.
AND HE DIDN'T ACT.
I MEAN, WE HEARD THIS FROM THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS,
WE'RE HEARING IT FROM THE ACTING
DEFENSE SECRETARY, AS WELL, THAT
THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T ACT.
I MEAN, LOOK AT THE SEQUENCE OF
EVENTS OF HAVING TO BE COAXED TO
FINALLY BELATEDLY SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT STANDING DOWN AND THEN
STILL CALLING THE RIOTERS
BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE.
SO I MEAN, I THINK THE STARTLING
REALITY OF WHAT WE'RE LEARNING
ABOUT JANUARY 6th IS WHAT WE
FELT WE KNEW FROM THE START,
THAT THE PRESIDENT KNEW WHAT HE
WAS DOING, WAS HAPPY TO SEE IT
COME TOGETHER THAT WAY, AND THEN
WAS NOT GOING TO GET IN THE WAY
OF STOPPING IT.
AND I THINK -- I WANT TO ADD
SOMETHING TO WHAT EVAN SAID
WHO'S COVERING THE INS AND OUTS
OF THE INVESTIGATION SO
CAREFULLY IS THIS QUESTION OF
INTENT REALLY IMPORTANT AS A
LEGAL MATTER.
AND IN THE INVESTIGATION.
WE CAN JUMP TO THIS QUESTION OF
WHETHER THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
MIGHT BRING A CASE AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
WE DON'T KNOW.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FACTS
ARE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
INVESTIGATION WILL GO.
THE QUESTION OF WHAT HIS INTENT
WAS, WHAT THEY CAN PROVE AND
WHETHER HE ACTUALLY ENTERED INTO
A CONSPIRACY WHICH MAY BE
SEPARATE FROM REACTION TO THE
RIOT ITSELF TO A FAKE ELECTORS
SCHEME.
YOU KNOW, KIND OF DIFFERENT
ANGLES IN THE SAME
INVESTIGATION.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU, DAVID.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, EVAN, THANK
YOU.
>> THANKS.